Tach zusammen, Jack Pop hier.
Ostern steht vor der Tür.
Für die Christen das wichtigste Fest des
Jahres.
Denn zu Ostern ist Jesus, laut Bibel, von
den Toten auferstanden und hat damit ein letztes
Mal seine übernatürlichen Fähigkeiten bewiesen.
Und da hab ich mich gefragt, hätte er vielleicht
seine ganzen Tricks auch irgendwie anders
hinbekommen können.
Also was, wenn der Heiland einfach nur ein
krasses Wissenschaftsgenie war?
Das checken wir heute gemeinsam und als erstes
zeige ich Euch, wie Ihr über Wasser laufen
könnt.
Deswegen drückt doch schnell abonnieren und
unsere Osterglocke und dann kann es losgehen.
Das Neue Testament in der Bibel ist voller
Wundergeschichten von Jesus; mit denen er
echt ziemlich gut rüberkommt.
Lass uns mal drei davon anschaue.
Punkt 1: Jesus läuft übers Wasser.
Die Story aus dem Matthäus Evangelium geht
so: Die Jünger von Jesus fahren mit einem
Boot raus auf den See Genezareth, der liegt
im Norden Israels.
In der Nacht kommt Jesus dann auf dem Wasser
zu ihnen gelaufen.
Was denen natürlich einen totalen Schrecken
einjagt, weil die Jesus erst mal für ein
Gespenst halten.
Wie kann er das denn gemacht haben?
Die wichtigste Frage dafür ist, ob sich das
Boot zu dieser Zeit in der Nähe des Ufers
befindet.
Denn am Westufer des Sees Genezareth wäre
der Trick überhaupt kein Problem.
Dort gibt es nämlich bis heute Salzwasserquellen
Diese Salzwasserquellen spielen eine wichtige
Rolle in der Theorie von Doron Nof.
Er ist Professor für Ozeanografie an der
Florida State University und hat sich das
biblische Szenario 2015 mal gemeinsam mit
zwei Kollegen angeschaut.
Ihrer Theorie zufolge ist salziges Wasser
aus den Quellen in den See Genezareth geflossen
und auf diesem Strom aus Salzwasser konnte
dann nachts eine dünne Schicht Süßwasser
gefrieren, eben weil Süßwasser schneller
gefriert als Salzwasser.
Es hat sich also eine Art Eis-Passage auf
dem See gebildet, die in der Dunkelheit auch
nicht vom restlichen Wasser zu unterscheiden
gewesen wäre und auf der Menschen laufen
konnten.
Das heißt, es war eine Art Eisbrücke zum
Boot hin.
Jesus ist also gar nicht übers Wasser gelaufen,
sondern lediglich über gefrorene Teile des
Sees.
Das ist das heutige Israel.
Da geht es doch im Winter nicht unter 0 Grad?
Heute vielleicht nicht, vor 2000 Jahren aber
schon.
Das haben Nof und seine Kollegen auch rausgefunden.
Sie haben Tier- und Muschelüberreste aus
dem Mittelmeer untersucht und konnten so sehr
lange zurückliegende Temperaturen rekonstruieren.
Und die haben festgestellt, dass es zu Jesu
Lebzeiten tatsächlich eine Kälteperiode
gegeben hat, bei der die durchschnittlichen
Temperaturen zehn Grad kälter waren als heute.
Wenn Jesus jetzt also wirklich ein Wissenschaftsgenie
war, dann hat er diesen nächtlichen Gefrierpunkt
natürlich kommen sehen.
Anhand seiner Kenntnisse von Atmosphäre,
Temperaturen und Umweltbedingungen und hatte
genug Zeit, seinen mysteriösen Auftritt vorzubereiten.
Und das steht sogar eine Bibel.
Und Jesus drängte die Jünger darauf, ins
Boot zu steigen und ans andere Seeufer vorauszufahren.
Er selbst wollte erst noch die Menschenmenge
verabschieden.
Als er damit fertig war, stieg er allein auf
einen Berg, um zu beten.
Als es dunkel wurde, war er immer noch da…
Seht Ihr!
Der hat die anderen vorgeschickt und dann
selbst gewartet, bis es dunkel geworden ist,
weil dem völlig klar war dieser Trick wirkt
extra krass, wenn er mitten in der Nacht wie
ein Geist übers Wasser anmarschiert kommt.
Und ich habe Euch ja versprochen, dass ich
Euch zeige, wie auch Ihr übers Wasser laufen
könnt.
Dafür braucht ihr gar kein Salzwasser, kein
See Genezareth.
Dafür braucht Ihr nur ein „nicht-newtonsches
Fluid“.
So ein Fluid kann man in großen Mengen herstellen.
Hier wurde zum Beispiel ein ganzer Pool damit
gefüllt und Menschen können darüber laufen
und sogar Fahrräderfahren darauf.
Aber schaut mal, nur solange, wie eine Kraft
wirkt.
Wer hier stehen bleibt, der sinkt ein.
Warum ist das so?
Die meisten Flüssigkeiten sind newtonsche
Fluide.
Das heißt vereinfacht, ihre Viskosität,
also ihre Zähflüssigkeit, ändert sich nicht,
wenn eine Kraft auf sie einwirkt.
Die fließen also immer gleich.
Wasser ist hier das beste Beispiel.
Wenn man Wasser jetzt aber mit Stärke mischt,
dann entsteht ein „nicht-newtonsches Fluid“,
das sich anders verhält.
Unter Krafteinwirkung wird das Wasser zwischen
den relativ großen Stärketeilchen verdrängt.
Die rücken also nah zusammen und reiben dann
so sehr aneinander, dass das Gemisch halt
nicht mehr normal fließen kann.
Also es wird spürbar zähflüssiger und bei
ruckartigen Bewegungen verhält es sich auch
noch wie ein Feststoff.
Die Viskosität, die steigt hier also an.
Rieseneffekt!
Den kann ich euch hier nochmal ganz cool zeigen.
Wenn ich jetzt mit meiner Faust auf diesen
Wasser-Stärke-Mix einschlage, dann verfestigt
er sich und meine Faust sinkt nicht ein.
Und es spritzt auch nicht.
Wenn ich das aber mit weniger Kraft mache,
dann sinken meine Finger ganz langsam in dieses
Gemisch hier ein.
Das ist echt ein ziemlich verrücktes und
cooles Gefühl.
Das könnt ihr alle selber nachmachen, indem
Ihr einfach ganz normale Haushaltsstärke
nehmt.
Punkt 2: Jesus verwandelt Wasser in Wein.
Diesen ziemlich coolen Partytrick zieht Jesus
laut Bibel auf einer Hochzeitsfeier ab, als
dort langsam der Wein knapp wird und der Gastgeber
blöderweise keinen Nachschub mehr da hat.
Was er aber da hat, sind sechs große Steinkrüge,
die eigentlich zum Waschen gedacht sind.
Irgendwann sagt Jesus den Dienern der Hochzeit
dann, dass sie diese Steinkrüge mal bitte
mit Wasser auffüllen sollen und… Tadda!
Alle plötzlich voll mit Wein.
Wie hat er das gemacht?
Wenn man sich bei YouTube umschaut, dann gibt
es tatsächlich eine Menge Videos mit chemischen
Schauexperimenten, die eine durchsichtige
Flüssigkeit rot einfärbt.
Das Problem ist aber, die Chemikalien, die
dort zum Einsatz kommen, sind A zu Jesu Lebzeiten
lange noch nicht bekannt gewesen, geschweige
denn herstellbar und B ungenießbar bis tödlich,
wenn man die wirklich trinkt.
Um aus Wasser also eine Flüssigkeit zu machen,
die auf den ersten Schluck wie Wein rüberkommt
und bedenkenlos trinkbar ist, hatte Jesus
vor 2000 Jahren also eine viel geringere Auswahl
an „magischen Zutaten“.
Eine Zutat gab es aber damals schon: Läuse.
Aus einigen Schildlausarten lässt sich ein
roter Farbstoff gewinnen, nämlich Kamin.
Das war in Lateinamerika schon lange vor Jesus
bekannt und Campari hat damit zum Beispiel
bis 2006 seine Drinks eingefärbt.
Das Problem ist, Jesus wäre da nicht rangekommen,
weil Lateinamerika noch in der unentdeckten
Welt lag.
Aber auch in Europa gibt es Schildlausarten,
die einen chemisch verwandten Farbstoff produzieren,
nämlich das unechte Kamin oder auch Kermes.
Das ist nicht ganz so farbintensiv und Jesus
hätte ein paar mehr Läuse dafür gebraucht.
Der Effekt ist aber genau der Gleiche.
Ich habe das mal recherchiert und nachgerechnet.
Um das durchsichtige Wasser in diesen sechs
Hochzeitskrügen bis oben hin rot einzufärben,
hätte Jesus zwölf Kilo von dem unechten
Kamin gebraucht und dafür mehr als eine Million
Läuse.
Es ist also völlig logisch, dass dieser Trick
in der ganzen Bibel nur ein einziges Mal vorkommt.
Jesus hätte dafür Zeit seines Lebens Läuse
sammeln und trocknen müssen.
Wenn er den Farbstoff hat, ist leider noch
nicht Schluss.
Denn Kamin löst sich schlecht in kaltem Wasser,
dafür aber umso besser in Alkohol, was für
Jesus eh viel cooler ist, denn so kriegt er
gleichzeitig noch ein paar Umdrehungen ins
Wasser mit rein… für das echte Weinfeeling.
Das Problem ist, reinen, hochprozentigen Alkohol
bekommt man nur über Destillation.
Also das Prinzip der Destillation ist schon
seit über 5000 Jahren bekannt.
Im alten Ägypten hat man damit ätherische
Öle hergestellt und Aristoteles hat schon
lange vor Jesus für Seefahrer beschrieben,
wie die aus Meerwasser über Destillation
trinkbares Wasser machen können.
Aber die erste Destillation von Alkohol hat
erst 900 Jahre nach Jesus stattgefunden.
Aber wenn Jesus wirklich einen Wissenschaftsgenie
war, dann war er natürlich auch seiner Zeit
voraus.
Also er hat das Prinzip der Destillation verstanden,
verbessert und zum ersten Mal für Alkohol
angewendet.
Das konnte er halt nur niemandem sagen, weil
sonst sein ganzer übernatürlicher Status
flöten gegangen wäre.
Das ist doch völlig logisch.
Das ist ja völlig konstruiertes Szenario.
Wenn Jesus da einfach vorher an den Wasserkrüge
rumhantiert haben soll.
Gar nicht konstruiert, lies mal die Heilige
Schrift.
In der Bibel steht das genauso drin!
Und als der Wein ausging, spricht die Mutter
Jesu zu ihm, sie haben keinen Wein mehr.
Jesus spricht zu ihr: „Was geht‘s dich
an Frau, was ich tue?
Meine Stunde ist noch nicht gekommen“
Aha!
Seine Stunde ist noch nicht gekommen.
Das heißt, er hat gerade keine Zeit, der
muss noch was vorbereiten.
So wie jeder gute Chemiker.
Ja aber rotes Alkohol-Wasser, das schmeckt
doch nicht.
In der Bibel lobt der Speisemeister den Wein
ja noch als besonders wohlschmeckend.
Eure Geschichte ist völliger Quatsch!
Nein, kein Quatsch.
Also erstens kann Jesus ja seine Wein-Grundmischung
noch mit ätherischen Ölen oder anderen Stoffen,
die halt damals schon bekannt gewesen sind,
geschmacklich und geruchlich angepasst haben.
Zweitens kommt hier noch ein ganz wichtiger,
psychologischer Aspekt hinzu.
Wein schmeckt nämlich umso besser, je höher
unsere eigene Erwartungen an den Geschmack
ist.
2008 hat ein kalifornisches Forschungsteam
eine Gruppe von Menschen ins MRT geschoben
und sie dabei zweimal den gleichen Wein verkosten
lassen.
Aber einmal wurde der Wein als billige Sorte
vorgestellt und einmal als edler Tropfen von
90 Dollar pro Flasche.
Der vermeintlich teurere Wein hat den Versuchspersonen
dann wesentlich besser geschmeckt als sein
günstigeres Pendant, obwohl ja beide Geschmacksproben
genau gleich waren.
Das heißt also, das Preisschild und die daraus
resultierenden Erwartungen an den Wein haben
messbare physiologische und psychische Auswirkungen
gehabt.
Für Jesus heißt das: Der Hype um ihn, sein
Charisma, sein Status als Wunderheiler…
All das könnte die Menschen um ihn herum
dazu gebracht haben, seine gepunchte Alkohol-Suppe
tatsächlich als leckeren Wein wahrzunehmen.
Cheers!
Punkt 3: Jesus stirbt, kehrt aber von den
Toten zurück.
Die Kreuzigung und alles drum herum, das lassen
wir mal außen vor.
Das dürfen eh nur die Typen von Monty Python
veralbern
Also lasst uns mal zu dem Moment vorspulen,
der am Ostersonntag im Fokus steht.
Nämlich der, wo der Leichnam von Jesus nicht
mehr im Grab liegt und er damit seine Ankündigung
wahr gemacht hat, nach drei Tagen von den
Toten aufzuerstehen.
Die Frage hier ist: Kann man mit wissenschaftlicher
Hilfe über mehrere Tage hinweg seinen eigenen
Tod faken?
Ja, mit einiger Kenntnis über Nervengifte
geht das, sagt die britische Chemikerin Kathryn
Harkup.
Die hat das für ein ganz ähnliches Szenario
untersucht, nämlich für den vorgetäuschten
Tod von Shakespeares Julia.
Das Gift, das Julia in einen todesähnlichen
Schlaf versetzt, soll 42 stundenlang wirken;
das kommt also ziemlich gut an die Zeit von
Jesus Abstinenz ran.
Kathryn Harkup sagt, dass Tetrodotoxin, ein
Gift, das von Bakterien in Kugelfischen produziert
wird, hier einen ziemlich guten Job machen
würde, weil es die Kommunikation zwischen
Gehirnzellen deaktivieren kann, was dann letzten
Endes zu Muskelerschlaffung und Lähmungen
führt.
Menschen, die eine derartige Vergiftung haben,
die können sogar bei Bewusstsein sein, das
dann aber halt nicht mitteilen, weil sie sich
halt nicht bewegen können.
In Japan, wo Kugelfisch eine Spezialität
ist, hat man früher deswegen vergiftete,
sogar neben ihre Särge gelegt und gewartet,
bis die Leiche irgendwelche Anzeichen von
Verwesung gezeigt hat, damit man nicht aus
Versehen jemanden lebendig begräbt.
Ja, aber zu viel Kugelfisch Gift ist tödlich.
Da steigt doch irgendwann die Atemmuskulatur
aus.
Klar, die korrekte Dosis rauszukriegen, ist
echt kompliziert.
Aber Kathryn Harkup sagt, wenn man das schafft,
dann ist ein gefaketer Tod durchaus möglich.
Im Mittelmeerraum kommen auch Kugelfische
vor und unter den Jüngern von Jesus waren
doch lauter Fischer.
Die Geschichte ist absolut plausibel!
Ja, selbst wenn der am Ostersonntag wieder
zu sich kommt, wie hätte der denn den riesigen
Stein vor seiner Höhle weg bewegt?
Dann guckt doch auch hier mal bitte wieder
in die Bibel.
Da steht nämlich drin, was passiert ist.
Und siehe, es geschah ein gewaltiges Erdbeben,
denn ein Engel des Herrn kam vom Himmel herab,
trat an das Grab, wälzte den Stein weg und
setzte sich darauf.
Seht Ihr!
Ein Erdbeben war es!
Ich meine, ob da jetzt wirklich ein Engel
war oder ob das alle Anwesenden gemeinsamen
halluziniert haben, ist ja jetzt Glaubens-
und Interpretationssache.
Aber Fakt ist, Jesus hätte in einem günstigen
Moment die Biege machen können, um dann später,
in vielen anderen Bibelstellen, als Auferstandener
in Erscheinung zu treten.
Zum Schluss noch etwas Versöhnliches: Ich
hoffe, ihr habt diese Folge, so wie ich, als
Gedankenexperiment verstanden, das Lust auf
Wissenschaft machen soll.
Ich will auf gar keinen Fall die religiösen
Gefühle von irgendjemandem verletzen!
Schreibt mir auf jeden Fall in die Kommentare,
wie ihr die Folge fahndet und auch, wenn Ihr
noch ein bisschen mehr zu diesen ganzen Herleitungen
und Rechenbeispielen wissen wollt.
Viele Infos haben es nämlich gar nicht erst
in die Episode geschafft, weil das sonst zu
lang geworden wäre.
Ich würde mich freuen, wenn wir ein bisschen
„Nerd-Talken“ können und noch mehr freue
ich mich über einen Abo.
Und wenn Ihr unsere Glocke drückt, dann sehen
wir uns nächsten Mittwoch schon wieder.
Bis dahin, Frohe Ostern!